protein
what is a
protein proteins play myriad
roles in the biological world some
transport nutrients throughout the body
some help chemical reactions
happen faster others
build the structure of
living things despite their wide range of
functions all  proteins are
made of the 21 building blocks called
amino acids amino acids are made
of carbon oxygen nitrogen and
hydrogen atoms and some have
sulfur atoms sele not cysteine is the only
common amino acid that contains a
selenium atom
these atoms form a group of friends
a  group of charges string and a
side chain attached to a central carbon atom
the side chain determines the
properties of an amino acid and is the
only part that changes from one amino acid
to another
hydrophobic amino acids have
carbon-rich side chains that
do not interact well with  water
hydrophilic or polar amino acids
interact well with water  wa
[Music
] charged amino acids interact with
amino acids of opposite charges or with
other molecules
[Music]
protein
structure primary structure
secondary structure tertiary
structure quaternary
structure primary structure the
primary structure of a protein is the
linear sequence of  amino acids
as encoded in dna
amino acids in a protein are held
together by peptide bonds that
link the amino group of an amino acid
to a car box group and ot a
water molecule is released each time
it is formed  a bond
linked series of carbon,
nitrogen, and oxygen atoms are the
basic structure of protein
protein chains frequently
fold into two types of
secondary structures alpha helices and
beta-pleated sheets
an alpha helix is a right-handed spiral
stabilized by bonds  of
hydrogen between the amene and
carb oxide groups of amino acids  nearby
[Music
] beta sheets form when
hydrogen bonds stabilize one or
more and adjacent amino acids
the tertiary structure of a protein
is the three-dimensional shape of the
protein chain the shape is determined by
the characteristics of the amino acids
that make up the protein chain  chain many proteins
take on globular shapes with
hydrophobic side chains shielded from
the inside away from surrounding water molecules
membrane-bound proteins have
hydrophobic amino acids clustered on the outside
so that the hydrophobic side chains
can interact with
membrane lipids amino acids
charged allow proteins to
interact with molecules that have
complementary charges
the functions of many proteins
depend on their three-dimensional shapes
for example hemoglobin forms a
pocket to hold the a
small molecule with an iron atom in the
center that binds with the o  oxygen the
quaternary structure two or more
polypeptide chains can join together to
form a functional molecule with several
subunits the four subunits of
hemoglobin cooperate so that the
complex more easily takes up oxygen in
the lungs and releases it in the body
representation of the protein the
different  visual representations
of proteins can give us clues
about their structures and functions
this diagram shows all the
atoms that make up this protein
this representation called the ribbon
or animated diagram shows the
organization of the protein chain
and emphasizes the helices
alpha representation of surfaces
shows areas on the protein that
are accessible to water molecules
size of protein most
proteins are smaller than the
wavelength of light e.g.
the hemoglobin molecule is
about  6.5 nanometers in size,
hemoglobin is  found in high
concentrations in red blood cells
a red blood cell
contains about 280 million
hemoglobin molecules
shape and function
three-dimensionally shaped proteins determine their function
defense antibodies the flexible arms
of antibodies protect us from
disease by recognizing and binding
to  pathogens and prop them up for
destruction by the immune system
communication communication insulin
the insulin hormone is a
small, stable protein that can easily
retain its shape as it travels through
the blood to regulate the level of
glucose in this
glucose transporter
enzymes  alpha amylase enzymes
alpha amylase is an enzyme that initiates
the digestion of starches in our
saliva
transportation transportation
calcium pump reticulum sarko plastic of
muscle cell calcium pump is
aided by magnesium and driven by
artest to return calcium ions
the zarco crosshair  plastic after
each muscle contraction
[Music]
and storage storage ferritin
ferritin is a spherical protein with
channels that allow iron atoms to
enter and exit depending on
the needs of the organism
inside ferritin forms a
hollow space with atoms attached to  the
inner wall and ferritin stores iron
in a non-toxic form
structure structure collagen
collagen forms a strong triple helix
that is used throughout the body for
structural support collagen molecules
can form elongated fibers
that join together to form
fibers  of collagen
[Music]
this type of collagen is abundant in the
skin and tendons
you can learn more about the functions and
three-dimensional structures of
proteins and other
molecular machines in the ars and it is big brohter
deira bank
[Music]